yo siento que la vida es como un paisaje
si seguimos esta metáfora del paisaje
hay momentos que son postales hermosas
que siempre queremos recordar y también
hay cimas que nos cuesta mucho subir
pero cuando las alcanzamos sentimos que
es una victoria y también hay baches
rupturas fragmentos que son estos
momentos de la vida cuando más energía
necesitamos de nosotros estos momentos
fragmento pueden ser por una enfermedad
por una pérdida amorosa o también por la
pérdida de un ser querido
en mi caso fue un diagnóstico de vih yo
soy juan de la mar y me diagnosticaron
vih-positivo el 17 de mayo del 2017
al inicio fue muy difícil para mí estuve
muy deprimido como un año y medio sentía
que me iba a morir todo el tiempo y me
despedía de las personas que quería
entonces literalmente yo vivía cada día
como si fuera el último y no como una
postal de una tarjeta de superación
personal siempre me estaba despidiendo
de las personas iba al eje cafetero a
visitar a mi familia me despedía me veía
con mis amigas me despedía y esto me fue
desgastando y me fue generando una
sensación que mi vida perdía color que
todo se lavaba y se ponía gris empecé el
tratamiento médico y a pesar que los
exámenes salían bien yo seguía sintiendo
esta sensación de muerte
hubo cosas que no me ayudaron desde el
sistema médico por ejemplo una vez fui a
una cita con un dermatólogo y él me dijo
las recomendaciones generales como
échate todos los días crema corporal y
bloqueador solar y yo le dije sí yo
siempre lo hago él me dijo es que a
ustedes se les empieza a poner la piel
como gris y yo me quedé sentado no fui
capaz de decirle nada porque yo sentía
que a las personas con vih lo único que
nos podían hacer sentir era vergüenza
me fui a una banca al frente de ese
consultorio a llorar y en adelante todos
los días me miraba al espejo porque
tenía mucho miedo que se me notará
entonces me miraba así se me estaban
marcando los huesos si los pómulos de mi
mercado si estaba más flaco más pálido
y esta época fue definitivamente muy
triste yo me sentía como la persona más
desafortunada y sola del mundo
desafortunada porque yo me cuidaba en
general yo usaba condón y cuando me
diagnosticaron yo dije como voy a hacer
la persona más de malas que me pasa esto
justo a mí y sola porque no conocía a
nadie vivo que tuviera vih
entonces yo hice una lista de las cosas
que quería hacer sin memoria las empecé
a hacer una a una y el último punto en
la lista era estudiar cine desde
chiquito había tenido esa en sensación
de emoción por las cámaras me inquietaba
la magia de las imágenes en movimiento y
dije bueno pues si no me he muerto voy a
cumplir el sueño más grande de mi vida y
con el apoyo de mi familia que siempre
han estado conmigo
inclusive en esta situación tan difícil
de entrar
cuando entré a la escuela de cine fue
increíble como como esa sensación de
estar cumpliendo el sueño más grande de
tu vida y yo sentía que las cosas podían
empezar a cambiar y así fue
cuando hoy la materia de documental tuve
la oportunidad de hacer un documental y
decidí hacerlo sobre mi propia historia
sobre mi relación con este diagnóstico
de vih
entonces con los compañeros que hicieron
parte de mi grupo empezamos a buscar
textos imágenes que nos ayudaran a
transmitirle al espectador esa sensación
de encierro de ahogamiento y yo encontré
un texto en el que decía que me quería
forrar en látex para no contagiar a las
otras personas me preguntaba cómo podría
caminar en una ciudad llena de bacterias
de virus y me preguntaba también cómo
forrar en látex el amor entonces lo que
decidí fue envolverme en látex y caminar
por bogotá y sus tráfico para que las
personas sintieran ese ahogamiento que
yo llevaba cargando un año y medio de mi
vida
hicimos este performance lo grabamos y
después para finalizar el documental yo
decidí hacer un ritual psicomágico un
acto en el que me envolvía en látex
totalmente me colocaba en el piso y las
personas que me habían acompañado aquí
en bogotá en este tiempo me acompañaban
en este espacio y hablaban que habían
aprendido conmigo en este tiempo sobre
la vida sobre la muerte sobre el amor
también y después de estar ahí como una
hora empacado en látex me empezaron a
desempacar y al final me pintaron de
color me llenaron de color todo el
cuerpo
para acompañarme en ese viaje simbólico
de regreso a la vida que fue como lo
llame
puede sonar muy gracioso pero al día
siguiente del ritual yo me sentía muy
diferente yo sentía que podía respirar
como que por fin podía entrar aire a mis
pulmones
y empezó a pasar como cuando emite es un
sonido que empieza a resonar y tiene con
muchos lugares que mi historia y mi
documental empezó a llegar a muchos
lugares entonces escribía artículos para
revistas de salud me entrevistaron en
radio nacional inclusive me
entrevistaron en canales de franja
nacional a horarios familiares para
hablar de mi experiencia con el
diagnóstico y de mi documental también
empezamos a mostrar el documental en
festivales nos empezaron a seleccionar y
se empezó a volver una cuestión
retroviral no sólo viral retroviral como
es el mismo vih
para mí es increíble pensar que en
noviembre del 2018 estamos finalizando
de grabar el documental y al año
siguiente en noviembre del 2019
yo estaba siendo nominado al premio
ciudadanos con buena energía de bogotá
que es un premio que destaca trabajos de
alto impacto en la ciudad y no solamente
al finalista más joven sino que era el
único que nos llevaba 20 años o 15 años
trabajando en una comunidad en un barrio
de bogotá pero me había atrevido a
hablar de un tema que sigue siendo tabú
en nuestro país
sin embargo lo más interesante para mí
no es eso y tampoco ha sido lo más
bonito con los chéveres que puede ser
salir en televisión que la gente conozca
tu nombre que te referencia para mí lo
más bonito ha sido que después de cada
proyección del documental después de
cada muestra del documental en un
festival después de cada artículo que he
escrito me escriben personas a mis redes
sociales y me dicen que les pasó lo
mismo que les diagnosticaron con vih que
están deprimidos que tienen ansiedad que
tienen miedo de morir y que cuando
vieron el documental se sentían
acompañados de alguna manera y que se
identificaban con mi historia también
preguntándome cómo contarle a su pareja
cómo contarle a su familia y yo empecé a
sentir que compartir esta información
era como hablarle a una parte de mí que
no tuvo quien le hablara como ese
referente que yo nunca tuve convertirme
en ese referente que no tuve y no
solamente personas cercanas al vih
también me empezaron a hablar personas
que habían
o cáncer u otras enfermedades que habían
perdido un ser querido o inclusive
solamente que se habían sentido en un
momento de su vida fragmentadas y que
sentían que en el documental cuando yo
regresaba a la vida era como que su vida
volvía a tener color y esto para mí
ha sido como magia como la magia del
cine que yo tanto admiraba
en mi caso fue el arte y soy una persona
muy afortunada porque tuve el apoyo de
mi familia puede entrar a estudiar cine
pero conozco otras personas que han
decidido estudiar un doctorado y se van
de viaje por el mundo venden todo o
deciden agruparse a otras personas para
luchar por causas comunes a las suyas
hoy ha pasado tres años y medio desde el
diagnóstico yo me encuentro de salud muy
bien emocionalmente también estoy mucho
mejor pero sin embargo yo me sigo
haciendo algunas preguntas yo me
pregunto cómo es posible que sigue
existiendo tanta discriminación y tanto
prejuicio frente a ciertos temas a tal
punto que en la cuarentena pasada
dejaron morir una mujer trans en bogotá
porque tenía vih no le prestaron los
servicios de salud me preguntó también
como en nuestro país no hay figuras
públicas que tienen vih lo asumen como
pasa en otros países porque es que esto
lo que significa es que si a un joven lo
diagnostican va a creer que se va a
morir va a decir no tomarse el
tratamiento o se suicida que
prácticamente es lo mismo y me pregunto
cómo es posible
en pleno 2020 no sigan echando de
nuestras casas nos discriminen en
nuestro trabajo y a veces sentimos que
no somos parejas elegibles solo por un
diagnóstico de vih
y yo creo que esto tiene que ver con el
silencio con ese silencio al que están
condenados algunos temas en colombia hay
cosas en este país que están prohibidas
hablar el suicidio la depresión el vih
siguen siendo temas prohibidos y por eso
yo decidí poner la cara y hablar de este
tema en todos los espacios que pueda
porque yo sé que hay sentadas personas
que han sentido en algún momento que la
vida se les ha quebrado
hoy después les va a pasar y van a tener
a quien escribirle a quién llamar
en una de las últimas proyecciones que
tuvimos del documental que fue virtual
nos vieron más de 5000 personas en dos
días en esa ocasión me escribió un gran
amigo de nuestra época y me dijo que a
él le asustaba que a mí me identificara
con vih que pensaran que yo solamente
era una persona que tenía vih y no un
activista un artista un ser humano que
le puede aportar mucho a esta sociedad
y yo siento que efectivamente a mí no me
define el vih si hay una palabra que a
mí me define es la resiliencia esa
capacidad de sacar belleza de este caos
como decía gustavo cerati y de convertir
una experiencia que en un momento
significó para mí el final de mi vida en
un aprendizaje que ahora puedo compartir
con otras personas que estén pasando por
depresión que hayan tenido intentos de
suicidio que tengan otras enfermedades y
les puedo decir que cuando tú sientes
que tu vida se acaba que todo el color
se pierde que se opaca es posible que
sea el inicio de una nueva vida la
oportunidad de volver a comenzar o la
oportunidad de volver a la vida como fue
mi caso muchas gracias